what advice would you give to
researchers uh trying to develop and
publish idea that have a big impact in
the world of AI so maybe
um undergrads maybe early graduate
students yep
I mean I would say like they definitely
have to be a little bit more strategic
than I had to be as a PhD student
because of the way AI is evolving it's
going the way of physics where you know
in physics you used to be able to do
experiments on your benchtop and
everything was great then you could make
progress and now you have to work in
like LHC or like CERN and
and so AI is going in that direction as
well
um so there's certain kinds of things
that's just not possible to do on the
bench top anymore and uh
I think um that didn't used to be the
case at the time do you still think that
there's like
Gan type papers to be written where like
uh like very simple idea that requires
just one computer to illustrate a simple
example I mean one example that's been
very influential recently is diffusion
models diffusion models are amazing the
fusion models are six years old for the
longest time people were kind of
ignoring them as far as I can tell and
they're an amazing generative model
especially in uh in images and so stable
diffusion and so on it's all the fusion
based the fusion is new it was not there
and came from well it came from Google
but a researcher could have come up with
it in fact some of the first
actually no those came from Google as
well but a researcher could come up with
that in an academic Institution
yeah what do you find Most Fascinating
about diffusion models so from the
societal impact to the the technical
architecture what I like about the
fusion is it works so well
is that surprising to you the amount of
the variety almost the novelty of the
synthetic data is generating yeah so the
stable diffusion images are incredible
it's the speed of improvement in
generating images has been insane uh we
went very quickly from generating like
tiny digits to the tiny faces and it all
looked messed up and now you have stable
diffusion and that happened very quickly
there's a lot that Academia can still
contribute you know for example um flash
attention is a very efficient kernel for
running the attention operation inside
the Transformer that came from an
academic environment it's a very clever
way to structure the kernel uh that do
that's the calculation so it doesn't
materialize the attention Matrix
um and so there's I think there's still
like lots of things to contribute but
you have to be just more strategic do
you think neural networks could be made
to reason
uh yes
do you think they're already a reason
yes what's your definition of reasoning
uh information processing
so in a way that humans think through a
problem and come up with novel ideas
it it feels like a reasoning yeah so the
the novelty
I don't want to say but out of
distribution ideas
you think it's possible yes and I think
we're seeing that already in the current
neural Nets you're able to remix the
training set information into true
generalization in some sense that
doesn't appear it doesn't happen
like you're doing something interesting
algorithmically you're manipulating
you know some symbols and you're coming
up with some
correct a unique answer in a new setting
what would uh illustrate to you holy
[ __ ] this thing is definitely thinking
to me thinking or reasoning is just
information processing and
generalization and I think the neural
Nets already do that today so being able
to perceive the world or perceive the
whatever the inputs are and to make
uh predictions based on that or actions
based on that that's that's the reason
yeah you're giving correct answers in
novel settings
uh by manipulating information you've
learned the correct algorithm you're not
doing just some kind of a lookup table
and there's neighbor search